good morning dear chair Dear honorable
members we mark this International Day
on 25th November annually as
unfortunately violence against women and
girls remains a pervasive violation of
human rights in the European Union and
around the world violence against women
and girls remains one of the least
prosecuted crimes and it is a key bir
to progressing on women's rights and to
safeguarding the common values of our
Union as a whole I thank this house and
its members for being a strong Ally in
keeping the eradication of violence
against women and girls high on the
European Union political agenda since
the adoption of the gender equality
strategy in 2020 we have achieved
significant progress in multiple areas
of gender-based discrimination and
equality transforming our political
commitments into meaningful
actions we remain inspired by the vision
vision of a brighter future and present
for women and girls in all their
diversity in particular those facing
gender-based and domestic violence this
year the European Union finally exceeded
to the Istanbul convention marking a
major step forward in making Europe a
safer place for women and girls the
European Union is now Bound by ambitious
and comprehensive standards to prevent
and combat gender-based violence in
judical cooperation in criminal matters
Asylum and not reement and in its public
administration but there is no single
solution to such a deeply ingrained
systematic issue this is why our
legislative proposal on combating
violence against women and domestic
violence is so important and I would
like to thank this house for your
invaluable support on this important
matter
The Proposal includes the
criminalization of certain offenses
amounting to violence against women such
as rape based on a lack of consent
female genital mutilation the
non-consensual sharing of intimate and
manipulated material as well as a cyber
harassment and cyber incitement to
violence or hatred Additionally the
proposal guarantees the protection of
victims of violence against women and
domestic violence as well as their
support and access to Justice and the
prevention of such forms of violence
compared to the Istanbul convention it
implements new obligations of the
European Union following following its
accession to that convention in judical
cooperation in criminal matters as
things stand time is running out to
adopt this directive before the upcoming
European
elections we must keep pushing for
progress European commission very much
appreciates the efforts of the European
Parliament negotiating negotiating team
and let me notably thank the two Co
reporters Evan nir and Francis fald to
ensure an outcome matching the ambition
of our
proposal looking ahead we are working on
a recommendation to prevent and combat
harmful practices against women and
girls as announced in our gender
equality strategy with this
recommendation we intend to encourage
member states to take action to address
female genital mutilation forced and
child marriages honor related violence
forced abortion and forced sterilization
and other harmful practices that
disproportionally affect women and girls
on 29th and 30th November the commission
will hold the first meeting on the newly
established European Network on the
prevention of gender-based and domestic
violence which will bring together
member State experts and key
stakeholders to explore emerging issues
and discuss new practices the role of
men and boys in the prevention of
gender-based and domestic violence is
key and will be a key focus of the
[Music]
network in the G7 setting the European
Union contributes to the strengthening
of the accountability of the leaders
political commitment and to ensure
gender mainstreaming is a cross-
sectorial principle in the G7 activities
we also continue to be fully engaged as
co-leader of the generation equality
Forum Action Coalition on gender based
vience and EUR and un women on the
International Day the commission is
joining the un's global campaign to end
violence against women the European
Union expresses its unwavering support
for women and girls who have suffered
from violence as victims and survivors
and we condemn the use of sexual and
gender-based violence as a weapon of all
we stand with our partners Civil Society
women's rights groups and human rights
defenders in their call for justice and
accountability thank
you thank you very
much our next speaker on behalf of the
group of the PE European People's Party
I'd like to give the floor to MZ seats
in 2019 we stand here tomorrow
uh the International Day for the
elimination of violence against women
which takes place on Saturday sadly as
we all know in this house we have an
epidemic of violence and even increased
numbers during the covid-19 pandemic and
I have to ask the question is there
another crime which is so widespread and
which is so relatively ignored if the
same numbers who are victims of violence
against women were victims of terrorism
or Gangland crime I think we would have
a much more robust response
there is legislative progress and we
know that we've seen it in this house
with Istanbul hard one and now we have
the opportunity to conclude a robust
directive right across Europe and the
first surprisingly of its kind to tackle
violence against women and domestic
violence Evan and myself are working
hard on this directive but I have to
tell you colleagues it is an uphill
battle with the council and I have to
wonder why on Earth are the member
states not rushing towards this coal
using really to be honest and say that
without robust relationship and
sexuality education we will never
overcome this phenomenon and crucially
refusing at present that the most
heinous crime of rape uh should be
included in the directive why is it so
hard for the member states to accept
this we have all sorts of excuses but
really if you're serious about this
issue surely rape should be included and
the issue of consent in any directive
and violence uh against women we know of
course uh that these attitudes and
issues we're dealing with are deeply
embedded in our societies we know there
are many cultural issues and we need to
organize the way we shape our
relationships and our power
relationships in our countries much to
do but I do want to invite Council to
adopt a very robust comprehensive and
committed directive that will engage all
of society so that we can really begin
to see a decrease in numbers and so that
maybe some years from now we will be
able to say that Europe is the first
continent to eradicate violence against
women thank
[Applause]
you thank you very much on behalf of the
Socialists and Democrats I'd like to
give the floor to miss G Perez
graas thank
you
contr
for
the European Union has uh ratified the
EB convention and we uh now are going
forward with a directive to eliminate
violence against
women ladies and gentlemen in the
council we would like to just recall
that your voice should join us
in fighting violence against uh
gender-based
violence keeping rape as one of the
crimes o only Yes means yes
consent any sex without consent is a
violation sexually exploiting a woman is
not just selling their body it is also
means that you force a woman to have sex
without her consent let us not lose this
opportunity to have a useful directive
to protect all women who suffer from
gender-based violence especially those
who have been raped they cannot be left
off outside of the cover of this
directive we also have to make sure that
we include it in the treaty anything
related to human trafficking and sexual
exploitation of girls and
women president rer Lon stated at the
very outset of her term that she would
come forward with this proposal however
this proposal is just not enough it's
watered down we need a proposal that
includes hate crime yes but that also
includes gender-based violence that is
much more than just a hate crime it is
the rate it is the violation of Human
Rights rights the most pervasive and
persistent in the world and it is a
violation of equality between men and
women only if we're able to do this will
we be able to have a definition of
gender equality that includes all types
of crime that are are punished uniformly
throughout the EU and that means that we
can prosecute those responsible and
protect the victims throughout the
entire EU and that make sure that no one
remains in impunity now I'd just like to
recognize and acknowledge all of those
organizations that are working in
defending human women's rights all of
those organizations that are working to
protect women who are victims of
gender-based violence and just
also a chance to remember all of those
who can no longer listen to this debate
because their lives were lost to male
terrorism Europe thank you very much now
on behalf of renew Europe we'd like to
give the floor to Mrs Rodriguez
ramz thank you another
year we're here to talk about this
terrible tragedy violence committed
against women and girls throughout the
world this is a cruel reality in the EU
too we have recent
data 50 women die at the hands of men
every
week we know that we sorely need a
directive to deal with gender-based
violence and I thought that our speeches
today would celebrate this directive but
we can't do that there's a reality that
we have to speak out against in this
hemicycle there's no political Drive in
the council to make progress on that
directive the path is littered with
obstacles and the problem is that rape
isn't being included in the list of
crimes but it must be let me be crystal
clear today this
Parliament this Parliament won't give
the green light to to a directive which
doesn't include rape as a
crime but there's a whole list of other
reasons why we won't accept that because
that would disappoint millions of women
throughout Europe many many women's
organizations who have been fighting
hard for this directive we won't offer
them a toothless directive where no
member State Chang is their legislation
to afford greater
protection and where there are no
internal
changes we want a directive that will
protect women's lives if we don't get
that then the message to the council is
clear we will not accept that directive
thank
you thank you very much on behalf of the
greens M
rank not one
more and then there is another one and
another one and another one like now in
Italy where a woman was brutally
murdered the suspect is her ex partner
again she's the 53rd case just in Italy
just this year I don't know how you feel
about this but I'm
furious because men believe that their
own their girlfriends their daughters
their sisters that they are the ones who
can take decisions over their lives
their freedom and their decisions a
belief that is so deeply rooted in
patriarchal Power Systems every man who
cannot accept that their wife wants a
divorce and chooses violence every
father who cannot accept that their
daughter wants to choose freely what
their job is going to be and chooses
violence every ex partner who cannot
accept that their girlfriend has a new
partner and chooses violence
all of these men are part of a bigger
patriarchal problem our societies have
to stand up to this violence that is why
the directive against gender-based
violence is so urgently needed including
of course as the colleagues have said a
strong and comprehensive definition of
rape and let me tell you this since I
can remember there have been a number of
member states who continuously told us
all the things that we cannot do from
the European level when it comes to
gender-based violence with legal
arguments that have been proven wrong
the debate around the Istanbul
convention clearly shows if we in this
Parliament give up the first time a
member state raises legal concerns we
won't get anywhere but if we fight we
can make it the EU is going to exceed to
the Istanbul convention a success
colleagues of this Parliament and the EU
is also going to adopt a strong
legislation against gender-based
violence and again it will be because of
the work done in this Parliament because
we know that we owe this to the many
victims of gender-based violence in
Europe and all the other women living in
Europe we are going to continue this
fight we are not going to give up thank
you very
[Applause]
much thank you very much now on behalf
of the ECR I'd like to give the floor to
Mion
president commissioner
colleagues now we must give the right
response to the dramatic situation of
violence against women it's clear that
current policy have not been able to
protect women sufficiently data shows
that insecurity has increased in Spain
49 women were killed by their intimate
partners partners in
2022 200,000 rapes
and and assaults as well in 2021 in
2023 some 1,000 rapists were uh saw
their sentences reduced this is
unacceptable to have any violence based
on gender and to simplify this to
gender or a supposed patriarchy that
pits men against
women other addictions Al
alcoholism
pornography influence of cultures that
do not respect women in Spain we have
experienced with this some 20 years of
gender radical laws some of
which that do not exist in any other
country and the result has been
horrible the idea of protecting women
has violated principal rights of law for
example equality before the law in no
civilized country would this be
possible Yes means yes these laws have
actually exposed women more the sea or
sea law in Spain now what we need to say
is that why in Spain do we have a
retical gender law and that does not put
an end to violence nonetheless so
perhaps we should be looking at other
things resour forces to protect those
who are at risk supporting safety on the
streets supporting victims of sexual
violence enhancing our model of a family
life where Women's place is enhanced
make sure that we prosecute make sure
that sentences are
served and make sure that these people
cannot go back to the streets and repeat
their offense and of course update the
laws that were supposed to eliminate uh
uh that should eliminate any bias thank
you thank you very much on behalf of the
iday group M Anderson but I don't see
here in the room therefore I should like
to give the floor to Mr M O for the left
h president thank you uh chair I thought
that I was dying this is what joho said
she was drugged by a senator uh with a
view to abusing of her and what was the
reaction of the senator Joel Gario he
said that his cat was dying yes you did
hear me because his cat was dying he was
authorized to attack a woman uh what
level of impunity do we have to reach to
dare to say something like this uh very
often it's a question of uh Power Stefan
Co a radio presenter or um other uh
famous people have been prosecuted um
for violence but it isn't just
celebrities who are involved uh you
Predators can be found everywhere on the
road in our homes at work in intimacy uh
you can go from a simple comment to a
physical attack uh how many of us
here have been victims of one of these
types of uh attacks
or aggression dear colleagues generally
speaking uh this sort of debate uh
brings together um participants of the
same gender all women and uh we still
have to contend with this impunity we
would not let the patriarchy uh win we
have more than uh we have thousands of
cases every year people want to exclude
uh from our legis ation the definition
of rape now whether Emmanuel Macon uh
likes it or not a sexual uh sexual uh
relationships without consent are an
offense and we want this to be in the
legislation women's bodies do not belong
to you nor does our consent belong to
you thank
you thank you very much now the next
speaker on behalf of the non-attached
members Miss
F thank you Julia ctin uh brutal death
has really um shaken uh public opinion
in Italy Julia was denied her right to
live she was denied her future she isn't
the only one in my country more than 100
women have been victims since the
beginning of the year more than 80 were
killed by members of their family or or
a person they had a relationship with uh
there are several uh parties however
including those in government who have
proven that they're simply not uh
adequate in dealing with um women's
rights the um Lega or uh fralia haven't
even supported the Istanbul convention
and uh our membership thereof um rape is
one of the most serious offenses uh
the most serious violation of Human
Rights we have to do something about
this on a preventative uh basis we have
to set up the appropriate preventive
measures any legislative social and
cultural initiative which protects women
will contribute to a safer and more
equal
future thank you very much
now um Miss
[Music]
president one year ago in this same
hemicycle on the 2022 International Day
for the elimination of violence we had
High Hopes it was going to be a first
European law dealing with domestic
violence and other violence against
women but every day seven women die at
the hands of their Partners so where are
we today there are stormy debates
between the Parliament and the
council Parliament has been ambitious
but the member states have been blocking
us or even dragging us backwards
including
France 100,000 women suffer rape every
year in the EU and what the commission
is putting forward is that rape is
unconsented sex sexual relations the
member states haven't even put forward
an alternative they just removed the
term rap
rap from the text there's no joint
sanctions there's no joint protection
it's gone and another example Force
marriage the parliament wants that to be
punished throughout the union again the
member states
refuse and
then uh safe houses for women we in the
parliament want to have a specific
number related to the
population and there might be a 70
percent increase but the council doesn't
want it and then further protection for
victims we have put forward uh tags for
the perpetrators which could be used to
monitor those perpetrators so they stay
away from their victims this seems like
common sense and yet again the council
refuses it now on sexual harassment in
the workplace the parliament says that
this continues to affect too many women
and that it should be Criminal ized
again again the council won't include
workplace
harrassment now the
directive cannot just be mere words it
must truly protect women we can't
continue to have this debate every year
in this
hemicycle as we celebrate the
International Day for the elimination of
violence against women we now need to
have action not just words we hear that
Europe drags its feet it's not the
parliament though that's dragging its
feet it's the heads of state and
government who are dragging their feet
they are blocking they refuse to make
any progress due to a lack of political
willingness we won't uh have some kind
of secondary or watered down
law thank you very much Miss
sincere women's and girls cry for help
sounds different but yet they are all
the same the response of our 27 member
states are however shameful an estimated
of 81,1 100 women and girls were
murdered intentionally 2021 more than
half of them were killed as a
consequence of domestic violence more
than 60% of women have experienced some
kind of violence on their phone or
online every third woman above 15 in the
EU is Survivor of physical or sexual
violence but these are not only figures
behind every and each number there is a
person a woman a girl a mother a
daughter A nurse a doctor even a
lawmaker no place is save homes schools
workplaces squares streets or social
media platforms women and girls are
continuing being punchbags and shooting
boards for men together with my co-chief
negotiator Francis Fitzgerald I'm
continuing the struggle to ensure that
our 27 member states understand that we
must have a strong directive to combat
this heinous violence but the year is
2023 and still a majority of Our member
states refused to include the most
important legislation as a part of the
package consent based rape legislation
since we introduced the legislation back
in 2018 in Sweden thanks to the women's
organization such as fata and under the
Social Democratic lead government the
sentences have increased with over
75% it is shameful that governments as
those in France and Germany still refuse
to understand that only yes
means yes to the two men that right now
are responsible for the decisions there
in France president Emanuel macron and
in Germany Minister of Justice Marco
Bushman I want to say how many more of
us women must be killed before you stand
on the right side of history and say
only Yes means
yes
thank
you now I'd like to give the floor to
miss
CH in March
2013 Eric ker took her dog for a walk
her ex partner ambushed her at her
doorstep he forcibly sedated her
stripped her and poured lie on her
genitalia causing third degree burns she
survived this brutal attack only to face
a different form of brutality from the
authorities because despite clear
evidence the prosecutor tried to Hal the
case perhaps not independently of the
perpetrator's political connections it
took eight year long years of litigation
to finally put him in prison but he will
soon be released and Erica does not feel
safe or supported recently she said the
following with years of therapy I
managed to process the crime but not
what the system did to me just stop and
reflect on these words her dual trauma
from The Vicious attack to the system's
betrayal A system that discredits her
testimonies that forced her to discuss
intimate details with hostile or simply
unprepared men and on this International
Day for the elimination of violence
against women remember the story of this
courageous woman Erica is an EU citizen
and like all victims she needs a much
stronger European union and EU willing
to push for comprehensive reforms to
protect them thank you very
much thank you very much and now give
the floor to miss
bck uh it is for the fifth and last time
that we are meeting in this chamber on
the occasion of the international day uh
for the elimination of violence against
women but it is for the first time ever
that we can say we have we have
succeeded we have successfully broadened
the catalog of Rights and Freedoms by
adding this Istanbul convention which is
a document concerning the rights of
women who are targets of violence
nevertheless this ratification process
was too lengthy uh women in Europe had
to wait far too long to hear from their
authorities that they are by their side
that they are on the side of women and
not on the side of perpetrators and this
is not all we need a comprehensive
legislation that would provide
protection to each and every woman Pro
protecting her against every kind of
violence gender based including rape and
including cyber violence a good and
Progressive directive could constitute
such a legal act this directive must not
be the result of a compromises between
political parties violence against women
is one of the most drastic forms and
expressions of gender-based
discrimination whereas freedom and human
rights are the fundamental values for
our community this is why the contents
of this directive must be a Manifesto
for the European union we need to give a
clear signal underscoring that the
European Union is a world leader in
terms of women's freedoms there will be
no European Union without equality and
human rights thank
you thank you very much now
missa president colleagues indeed it's
the first time that we meet to call to
uh remember to talk about statistics to
talk about V
violence but uh what we should do for
our mothers sisters and colleagues to be
next next to them uh with them every
single day and not only once a year we
should stand next to them and we should
pressure our governments what I have
missed for the past 5 years would be an
analysis a comprehensive analysis of the
system as a whole because it's not
enough to quote data and information we
need more information how Education
Works how Justice Works to understand
why
in some of the systems it just Bears No
Effects we live in the 21st century we
have women who are educated who know
their
value I would just like to give you an
example of such actions because uh we
have managed in Poland to do so uh above
any uh political divides we've
introduced new laws and will introduce
more that laws that will separate the
perpetrator from from the victim
immediately from day one so any
perpetrator of uh uh where there is a
risk to health of uh the family needs to
leave the residents immediately with
immediate effect and they also are baned
to approach the residents uh for the
subsequent 15 days and police treats
this as a priority so there is new
competence for our um Law and Order
forces and they know that victims have
been traumatized so even when they are
uh when they come to give testimony they
are provided with special care this is
what Poland has done I hope that Europe
will do it as well with no device thank
you thank you
chair
um I've always wanted to have a little
girl to be able to uh play dolls to take
you to dance class piano class to give
you uh some advice when you grow up when
you will uh start falling in love you'll
have a few disappointments but you'll
manage to get up again if I have will
have been a good woman a good mother I
will teach you to believe in yourself to
be independent psychologically and
financially to love somebody but without
denying yourself I think that when you
are old enough to understand you should
never accept any attack any violence
even if it's minimal or apparently
harmless not even a joke I will teach
you to report to defend yourself to
learn to take your distance from people
who will want to wound you and um I will
teach you to hate
violence not to be subjected to violence
um grow up and never regret being a
woman be proud keep your head high
remember to uh to love uh with all your
heart and without any fear this is the
message I wrote to my daughter when she
was born four years ago and I think that
the first message the first way we can
help women emancipate is at in the home
the first results which were obtained
were obtained thanks to the awareness of
women
who uh gradually became aware of their
independence we have to defend our
freedom and our awareness unfortunately
there are very few men in the house
today there are all women here that's
the question we should ask ourselves is
this something which only concerns women
or does it concern men as well does it
concern uh mothers and fathers yes both
both have a task which is to educate
their
children thank you very much and now
give the floor to Miss Rodriguez
palop thank you
president today is another International
Day for the elimination of violence
against women the last during this
parliamentary term we have mixed
feelings in the fem
committee we have fought hard to prose
prosecute the perpetrators and protect
protect victims
yet we have not managed to
get violence against women included as a
European crime and yet we do have a
potential directive but we need to move
forward with this
directive how can the member states
refuse to include rape as a specific
crime we can't
have a directive which Falls below the
Istanbul
convention if it is non-consensual sex
then that is tantamount to rape only Yes
means
yes there are also changes underway to
the directive on human trafficking we
need to deal with the
traffickers but there are also women who
have to deal with misogyny every day
including at the hands of the extreme
right it's ter able that there's more
and more male chauvinism in the
institutions Vox the political
party
uh is teaching
cruelty and they are indifferent to the
plight of women we know that the
achievements we've made are
precarious and there is a risk of
backpedaling that we as feminists will
try to to prevent
that thank you very much the next
speaker is Mr castaldo however he's not
here so I give the floor to miss
tavu dear colleagues today is the
International Day for the elimination of
violence against women and our duty is
to unite against um this type of
violence
the European Union is United against uh
violence against women it's promoting
policies which are to protect
fundamental rights particularly the
fundamental rights of women we have now
joined the Istanbul
convention which is designed to uh
combat a gender based uh violence this
is a model
for dealing with this offense it also so
um is a model which can be used in order
to provide support to uh uh victims this
must be incorporated into our
legislation this is
important if we are to protect women in
and they are to live in an
environment without any fear and they
must be sure that their rights will be
recognized I would like to thank uh the
uh colleagues uh working in the
committee for gender equality for uh
their uh commitment we would like to
speak out against any form of violence
and promote equality and respect for all
women thank
you thank you very much now miss pno and
thank you very much president
colleagues yet another year and we are
here yet again looking upsetted with
anger at the long interminable list of
women who have been killed
battered annihilated and to say to us
yet again time is running out and to
remind ourselves to Recall yet again
that women are not dying because of a
natural disaster they're not dying
because an earthquake brought them down
or flooding they are dying they are
being
killed all of them at the hands of men
their intimate Partners their boyfriends
their ex-boyfriends
men here we're talking about
murder a crime a crime committed against
the victim but here we know we have a
group of women that are all that are all
victims the victims are all women and
the perpetrators are all men and these
men need to be arrested we need to stop
that culture that feeds into this
violence
and there's a clear name for this it's
patriarchy here we are yet again to
recall the fact that for months and
months we've been trying very hard to
make progress on this work this European
Parliament is doing much but it's not
enough yet it is not enough yet because
we haven't got even a basic text a
reasonable one a real basic one with uh
two things two fundamental
things without consent it's violence and
that we have to make sure that that
consent is the basis for the blood of
our sisters that we can't just wash away
and the memory of them that we have to
continue this B this uh fight for them
this struggle for them we will do that
and for with them we will change
all thank you very much the next speaker
is m Miss
Melo thank you very much colleagues
thank you very much commissioner I have
a lovely speech with uh facts and
information about the violence committed
against
women but we know the facts all of you
in this room know about the hundreds and
thousands of women that are being killed
that are being raped that are being
victims of violence I don't need to
repeat this to you I want those of you
that are not in the room today to take
this seriously
and we are not moving in the right
direction last week in raichi there was
a presentation of the raich index
showing the view of our populations of
women as
Leaders as of women as human beings in
the UK in Canada and in the US this year
there are less people in our population
that respect women as equal human beings
at the same level as men we have a huge
danger in front of us we have
authoritarian politicians that are
attacking women as equal human beings
and we have center right center left
politicians that are afraid of their own
values that are afraid of standing up
for the defense of women and therefore
are afraid of implementing the correct
definition of rape which is if there is
no consent there is no sexual
intercourse there is no no sex there is
only rape no means no and yes means yes
and women are capable of giving consent
and men are capable of respecting it
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you thank you very much the next speaker
is Miss
Reba president commissioner when we talk
about gender-based
violence this is something concrete
tangible present in our
lives one in three women and girls
suffers this kind of violence it's all
around us thus it's an obligation to
root it
out and I must therefore speak out
against the council
position
their position on the future directive
on violence against women we can't
accept Europe European legislation which
lacks ambition European legislation
which won't help us deal with this evil
and which doesn't
include rape based on non-consensual sex
as a
crime the EU just recently ratified the
Istanbul convention that should be the
Baseline the minimum standards not the
highest yard stick and I see that the
council is sorely lacking today I wish
that Council would change its attitude
and would be more constructive as part
of a feminist
Europe that's the Europe we're building
with difficulty let's see what happens
in the future
negotiations hopefully we can have an
agreement which will actually save lives
thank you very much the next
speaker should be Mr
Tes however he's not here so I give the
floor to miss
Andre
on the 4th of August 2023 in shour a
gentleman was sentenced for sexual abuse
of a sister who was only 12 and then he
managed to um get into a house and beat
somebody up so much that uh she was
totally um uh injured very seriously
injured and um the people who had to
look after her were reduced to tears in
arante um a gentleman entered the room
of elderly women and attack them
sexually um he was known by the police
for similar events but he was released
48 Hours afterwards the two women died
shortly after this
violence so this is the daily horror uh
Europeans have to um
watch now attackers want to destroy and
soil as well as enjoy
themselves um what is really upsetting
is that you are cowards migration has
contributed considerably uh to uh the
increase in sexual abuse over the past
10 years they're guilty but you're
responsible you're the people who allow
the men and uh you um pass laws with the
help of Nos and and subsidies um you are
are the people who are responsible so if
you want a to see a drop in violence
against women then stem the inflow of
these uh individuals who simply have uh
no respect for
women Miss
Pera thank you very much president here
we are yet again talking and
commemorating the international for the
elimination of violence against women
this is not just another day but yet a
manifestation of our commitment and our
support to those women who are
discriminated against and where violence
is p perpetrated against them now women
are subjected to different types of
violence
FGM work sex work trafficking battering
murder rape all of these things are a
part of discrimination and the unfair
treatment of women the fact that there
is not protection of the physical and
psychological Integrity of women that
this is a violation of all of the rights
of all of the women and we should look
then at how to persecute this violence
against women with instruments of
prevention that actually has an impact
on the daily life of women we must focus
on prevention and work towards the
elimination moreover it's fundamental
for the member states to take all of the
measures necessary to protect women with
a public decentralized n uh Network to
protect the women the victims to make
sure that there's also
training uh sounding the alarm and the
measures necessary to support them we
need robust funds there and political
will as well violence against women is
not something that we can do by delaying
it we have to make sure that we are
attacking this there shouldn't be anyone
who is uh not held
accountable thank you very much I now
give the floor to miss P
Canan thank you very
much what's happening towards
women this kind of violence is a Scourge
the planet
over it's 2023 now and it's
unbelievable that we are even still
talking about this that we even have to
still talk about protecting women and
their
rights so that they can live safely in
our societies it just Beggars
belief and yet one once again we're
talking about this and of course this is
a European Union issue now admittedly
the EU has ratified the Istanbul
convention this means that in our
legislation we Outlaw all violence
against women which is undoubtedly a
good thing however perhaps we ought to
be more insistent with the council
asking the council to do a lot more
because there are countless forms of
violence against women and they need to
be tackled via this directive rape needs
to be included as one of the crimes in
the directive it's only in that way that
we'll make any progress I think that the
member states need to do a great deal
more but I think that we need to work
together as Parliament Council and
commission women are human beings
that means they are people who enjoy
rights fundamental rights which cannot
be trampled upon and women's rights are
fundamental
rights that means that women's have the
right to do as they see fit with their
own bodies women have the right to live
safely without being subject to violence
they must be able to access uh Services
if Unfortunately they are victims they
must receive
support so all of us must act so that we
end this kind of violence against women
once and for all we have to do it at
home and elsewhere thank you very much
and now give the floor to Mr
Anga I'm glad that finally we have
ratified the Istanbul convention as a
European Union but I asked myself why
did it have to take so long when our
values are so clearly enshrined in our
treaty but the Istanbul convention alone
is not enough this week in Malta and my
country we remembered the murder of
Bernice kasar last year murdered by her
former husband the stul convention alone
did not save her we need to change
hearts and Minds we need to empower
women and young girls in our schools we
need to give men and young boys a
reality check and I urge all members
States and I start from mine Malta to
stop the resistance that we are
currently finding in the council in
including a clearly
defined rape in the directive on
gender-based
violence rape is a result of no consent
and this must be written down in the
directive and we need to do it now so I
start from my home country we did it at
home let's do it now in the European
Union thank
you thank you very much and I'll give
the floor to miss
to president dear colleagues every year
we celebrate that the inter ational day
for the elimination of violence against
women and every year we realize that we
haven't really made much progress the uh
number of women being killed is going up
rather than going down and yet many
states have adopted measures stemming
from the Istanbul convention and have
adopted um bold legislation and the
European directive will be a step in the
right direction against uh gender based
violence but let's look at the hemicycle
today um there are very few uh men here
they do not come along to express their
indignation so above and beyond laws and
standards what we really need is a
cultural revolution when will we see men
demonstrating against uh gender-based
violence uh on our streets everything
begins at school uh there are courses
organized in some countries could I ask
the commission uh about how that type of
measure could be made more European
because our children have to learn no
possession control jealousy are not
tantam out to love it's the legacy of a
male based uh society which we have to
fight against everybody has to fight
against this thank
you thank you very much and I'll give
the floor to Miss
K thank
you we
read in the headlines every day about
sexual assault and women are
consistently the
victims women who are exposed but
there's always a he in the
news a
man that's not necessarily in this same
headline but yet these are
attacks and sometimes the crimes are not
included in EU legislation but they must
be
now there is a lack of
specific legislation against
rape based on the concept that only Yes
means
yes in police headquarters
often what we see is that many of the
victims have to
face the fact that they were
somehow um complicit in the crime and we
need the exhaustive list of legislation
to make sure that we have domestic
violence as a law as a
crime president commissioner colleagues
I'm glad that the European Parliament
takes a position on this has this debate
and I'm glad that this is a subject that
actually unites us uh across the
political
Spectrum I think it's a very important
message that should come out of this
room and go into the world I think that
unanimity on this matter or almost full
unanimity on this matter is something
very much needed very much
expected we can talk about various forms
of violence sometimes it's systemic
violence
sometimes in some countries of Africa or
Asia it's the type of violence
that maybe is rooted to some extent In
some cultures or cultural aspects
but it still constitutes violence and in
the 21st century we should state it very
clearly it is
violence even if
it's culturally
motivated rooted in
culture we should definitely say no to
this form of violence even if it's
socially accepted in some area is so I'm
glad we have this message today thank
[Music]
you thank you very much and
Mr President colleagues today is the
International Day for the elimination of
violence against women like every year
we have nice warm words but they don't
help it gets worse there are more
murders there's more rape there's more
domestic violence more great uh group
rape and FGM as well and who is doing
this men but often they're
migrants men who were on the streets in
Germany and they celebrated
Hamas they
celebrated group rape and people being
headed even babies and in Essen where
I'm from there were 3,000 islamists on
the street 3,000 who said we hate Jews
they said we hate gays they made it
clear that they think women are useless
and worthless if you want to protect
women then you have to act and send them
back because these people shouldn't be
in Europe or
Germany you have a blue card from Mr
botos do you accept
it there is a blue card from Mr Botto
you
accepted Mr ra last time I asked a
question I asked in German but now
please put on your headphones to listen
to Romanian my mother tongue it is a
Pity that you in this debate should have
this uh uh hate speech because this hate
speech leads to this violence that
you're talking about it is a pity for
the Parliament and for this particular
day that you should um do this to to
this very important debate you should be
ashamed of yourself Mr you have 30
seconds for your
answer
Mass rape and the beheading of
women we have to be able to speak about
that openly even in this Parliament I
just simply won't tolerate that thank
you thank you and now uh we have gura
for one
minute thank you president um the um
violation of the fundamental rights of
women uh takes place every day one out
of three women has been subject to some
sort of physical or psychological
Violence by their partner or their
former partner and two out of three uh
do not report this and this violence um
which is at the very root of uh uh the
uh patriarchal of patriarchal society um
is linked to the idea that women are
inferior to uh men we
need to correct this
mindset we need to ensure that uh
violence perpetrated against women uh is
uh done away with we need to protect
victims and victims children in order to
ensure that Society does progress and
grow we have to ensure that rape is
clearly recognized as an offense no is
no thank
you thank you president violence against
women is a serious violation of Human
Rights it prevents peace equality and
all other human rights one in three
women continues to be a victim to
violence on a daily basis we see this
type of violence against women now
Europe has ratified the Istanbul
convention and the road map and now
we're working on a directive on VI
elimination of violence against women so
a Global overarching Response and it's
important for the ep's vote to be
factored in in the council's position
now when we have a lack of political
will we need to make sure that we have a
societal awareness of what we need to do
uh to fight this and that's precisely
what we're doing that's what's happened
in uh Spain what we saw was that some
1,200 saw their senten reduced and many
rapists were freed meanwhile we see the
number of women that are being killed
are are uh is increasing the law that
meant all that all of this took place
had took months to be changed and more
than five years has been there without
any consequence now this sends a message
to the world that it is not a priority
to save women's lives or to protect
their rights now
the message has not been clear about
the uh yes me means yes in fact the
Spanish message has not been clear
whatsoever and M Garcia Perez should
take full measure of this what we see in
the government in Spain that there is a
ideological position and this is the
wrong way forward many of those who are
sitting here in this chamber haven't
even spoken out on this subject and many
of them haven't done anything to change
the situation I should like to conclude
now the European Parliament had a
mission to look at this subject in Spain
amongst other things and the conclusion
of this from this
Mission with the consent of the fem
group and the uh left group have been
paralyzed I would like this to change
the rights of women do not have any uh
there's no ideological ideology that ens
that thank
you thank you and now rner
thank thank thank you
president vice president colleagues I
have a short but simple message we in
the parliament are against the
systematic violence committed towards
women we want a package that will
protect women from
violence and of course you need to
include rape on the list of crimes let
me remind
you we only managed to to get the
Istanbul convention ratified because we
in the parliament fought for it we asked
for the legal basis to be introduced and
it happened so I say to
the uh Council look there is a strong
legal basis you must include rape in the
list of crimes and of
course to include rape well yes is yes
that's that's the definition so I turn
to the council please accept your
responsibility there is
systematic violence committed against
women and we've got to end it once and
for
all thank you Mr gor has the
floor let's um tell the truth half of
Europeans are secondhand citizens right
now half of Europeans get paid less for
equal work half half of Europeans are
being harassed on a daily basis half of
Europeans are being harassed abused
killed and there isn't a huge punishment
for perpetrators these are Europeans
that go to school that go to work that
pay taxes that raise their
children these are the daughters the
wives the mothers of all of
us and they are people
just like women that today you see with
a black eye and tomorrow you don't see
her at all because there is no crime
done out of love love doesn't kill but
the indifference of European authorities
is star and these are just this
shouldn't be just empty words we need a
Relentless Justice against the harassers
against the rapists and a ruthless
Justice against the criminals otherwise
we will not do
[Applause]
anything thank
you thank you
president violence against women and
violations of human rights is pervasive
around the world some one in a third
women at some time in her life has been
subjected to
violence eatings or Cuts or in the worst
case honor crimes feminicide and we see
these crimes here in Europe we can add
to this child pornography as well as
kidnapping and uh trafficking we've seen
that there has also been an economic
boom
countries uh actually have a crime on
domestic violence but yet at the same
time they
are
somewhat tentative when it comes to
consent in the law within the framework
of that and it's often a weapon used in
Conflict areas what we need to do then
is to carry out a full fight to make
sure that rape is a crime that anything
where where there's non-consent no means
no yes means yes this should be
integrated into the directive to mean
that this is the Europe would be the uh
uh first continent to eradicate VI uh
gender based violence thank you thank
you
mron thank you president Madam
commissioner dear colleagues in the
Netherlands there are people who uh keep
guard by abortion centers very often
they're volunteers who tell women that
there are alternatives they provide help
be it Financial practical social or
psychological they provide help to
mothers and their children and this is
the way lives are saved and at the
moment um there are negotiations on a
directive to combat violence against
women and domestic uh violence now this
is a very important uh topic uh it's a
very important legislative proposal but
there is in the Mandate of the European
Parliament there is a mandate H to
prevent um abortion being qualified
being called an
offense so if I am talking with a woman
who is thinking about
abortion and if I uh suggest to her that
she think about um alternatives to
abortion surely I will not be liable to
be prosec cuted that cannot be uh
through so somebody who would try to
protect The Unborn Child someone who
would try to prepare to help a woman in
need if she if these people are not
allowed provide this help surely that is
a ruthless uh tactic so I think that
this part of the package should be
reviewed uh what we have uh in front of
us in this provision is simply without
any hope thank you
ker Miss toi
president colleagues 2023 has not come
to a conclusion and yet we have 105
women who were killed in Italy alone
Julia chadine who was brutally killed
the day before she was set to graduate
now the family and all of the families
of victims are um in our thoughts we
send our condolences but let these not
be empty words let us do something
tangible such that this doesn't happen
anymore in Italy we are working on this
throughout all the institutions at all
levels indeed the strengthened red code
is a preventive measure in
Lombardy we started the legislative
procedure to start with a double murder
the crime thereof where there be an um
an increase when there's are extenuating
factors and we would like to see this
happen in all of the member states in
Europe we recognize the fact that a law
will not be able to save lives if we
don't do something in the runup at
school educating children at school and
indeed our government has this in the
pipeline moreover we have to fight
patriarchy now the left
you've heard well for once we agree with
you let us fight the patriarchy but the
real one the real one of in uh of uh in
islamism with you you would like to
see women who would be subjected would
wear a head scarf and would not be
freed thank you Mr
B
thank you very much we continue to see
violence committed against women and
girls it's structural but it affects us
all it's an issue for all of
us we
see that these women's rights are
limited because these women can't
contribute to society sometimes they
even lose their lives we really need to
strengthen the laws we need to provide
better protection for those who
suffer and we need women shelters to
have more resources and more recognition
for them we need a strong feminist
movement which fights hard for the
rights of women and
girls and we need
to deal with the men and the boys who do
this this isn't what being a man is
about you can't buy woman's body you
can't uh um you can't buy sex from a
prostitute because that is tantamount to
violence too we have an opportunity to
accept responsibility we have
legislation against uh trafficking of
girls and women that is needed we need
that legislation we also need
legislation a directive on uh violence
against women where um there has to be
consent and only yes is
yes thank you very much Mr
guo thank you very much president
commissioner
colleagues this is a debate which is
relevant to all men and women
alike violence against women is
widespread it is a widespread and
systematic violation of Human Rights
and it happens in the EU too
unfortunately one in three women has
suffered physical or sexual violence
often at the hands of an intimate
partner now the EU does have various
initiatives and various actions that it
has taken but the figures are alarming
and the problem has various forms
physical emotional Financial reprodu
acve and even online this violence also
has a major impact on society as well
estimated at € 290 billion EUR per year
in the EU the UN instruments as well as
Council of Europe instruments are
extremely important as is the Istanbul
convention however we also need to have
an overall holistic policy involving all
um stakeholders I welcome the fact that
there is a gender equality strategy for
2020 to 2025 and that the council is
working on a directive to deal with
domestic violence
however there are similarities between
the national policies on combating
violence but the member states have
different approaches despite having
similar legislation we need more Europe
so that we can end violence against
women thank
you
thank you Mr
Goot the anti violence law from kit to
Lisbon together with Madame kokalari we
uh made sure that the Istanbul
convention is adopted across Europe a
Social Democrat and a PPP PPE member uh
the Liberals the left the conservatives
the greens all together however this is
not enough what we need is an ambitious
uh gender um directive that would fight
gender-based violence let's look at
Poland as you know we recently had
elections we had um an impressive
turnout uh so many women went to vote
and actually it was the votes of women
that changed um the situation so with
abortion we won't uh be uh letting go
either uh the left has already submitted
a new proposal of law when it comes to
abortion for instance we know it's a
right of every woman irrespective of
whether Mr Kinski like it or
not domestic terrorism kills thousands
of women every year and hundreds of the
children boys and girls all of this is
based on discrimination and Prejudice
that have been instilled in people's
minds subconsciously and that is why we
have an urgent responsibility we have to
identify and combat any inequality to
learn and to teach how to eradicate that
in our daily lives now we have to assume
the fact that equality is a basic tenant
of our quality of rule of life and
acting accordingly so we have to work to
fight the abuse of power domination and
the Prejudice that drive the murders of
women and denounce for example the early
consumption of pornography that OCC
occupies the area that has been left
free by hypocritical prudish opposition
to sexual education in school support
training of police judges victim care
units gender violence join the
demonstrations condemning sexist crimes
rebel against all of those law laws that
would curtail women's rights that
threaten our sexual and reproductive
Health on our path to equality any stop
is a step backwards in Europe in a
Europe of values no member State can
turn its back on the Ean B uh convention
thank
you thank you m
vand
president commissioner
women died in
Spain at the hands of men this week this
year excuse me
this is just the tip of the iceberg the
misogyny that is deeply rooted in our
society lives destroyed by male
chauvinism on the 25th of November we
speak out
against
feminicide and this cross-cutting
violence some of this violence is
visible some of it is invisible and
hidden this violence
is present
and there are thousands of
complaints against this kind of violence
in galsia every year but we see how the
extreme right instrumentalizes this
debate we need to put on our purple
glasses so that we can detect this kind
of violence only in that way can we have
a more egalitarian society here in
Europe and throughout the
world
um feminism in galaa will not go away
thank
you thank you Mr
David
president European Union seems to be
wishing to fail because it sets in
aievoli can be contained but not
eliminated the root causes for violence
against women are twofold aggression due
to hormones and antisocial and primitive
Behavior due to failed
upbringing some individuals cannot be
disciplined and are not affected by
punishment however harsh it may be if
the declared ambition were lower more
realistic that is to reduce violence
against women then we should focus on
education uh towards respect and without
abusing physical strength furthermore we
would have to drastically contain the
influx of Muslim immigrants with their
ideology demanding obedience and
subordination of women by force uh
female genital mutilation so-called
honor murders of disobedient daughters
and sisters no go zones are outside
police control unless we drastically
contain migration from Islamic countries
we cannot secure safety and proper
education Declaration of the
international dation is violence against
women's pure
hypocrisy Madam
watch there will always be more tears
more women uh more women murdered by
their Partners uh women kidnapped and
tortured in war zones women raped by
strangers femicide female genital
mutilation sexual assault revenge porn
online abuse women live in
fear Irish woman Ashley Murphy went for
a very simple run on a bright Wednesday
afternoon in January and she was one of
12 women murdered in Ireland last year
every year we shed tears uh over
senseless and inhumane acts of violence
against women and there's times where I
wonder Have We Become desensitized to it
all certainly my colleague who spoke
before me has no emotion at all towards
it or women who lose their lives many
women no longer feel safe when they're
out for a walk or waiting for a bus for
many home is not even safe most of us
know someone who's been sexually
assaulted more and more of us are
recognizing that we or people we know
have experience domestic or emotional
abuse and those numbers are rising and
there are tears fearful empathetic angry
tears there are always more victims
there are always more women we have
failed to protect and today let us take
the time to recognize that we have not
made European women feel safe and let's
take a moment to recognize the fear
Still Remains let us also take those
tears that emotion that anger and turn
it into change
and fundamentally call out the
nonsensical commentary from the extreme
right like my colleague before we cannot
drag our heels on the violence against
women directive and I call on EU
governments Spanish missing here today
to push for an agreement on this
immediately if we are serious about
protecting women and young girls G Mah
thank you very
much thank
you
colleagues I want to share an experience
with you I'm a German
me and this might be the fifth time that
Germany has blocked something in Council
but we have it already implemented in
Germany what about the women on boards
directive we already had that in Germany
but Angela Merkel blocked it in Council
we have something similar happening
again no means no yes means yes that
already exists in Germany so can how can
it be that when we speak to the German
Justice Minister why why are you
blocking
it why are you blocking it if it's good
for German women but then you're
blocking it for European women so that
they're on an equal playing field I
don't understand it Bushman the justice
jce Minister from the fdp is blocking
rape being included on the list of
crimes for the violence directive how
can it be how can it be that such a big
country such as Germany is causing this
grid loocking Council I don't
understand thank you and now Madame Han
has the
floor
colleagues we've heard that violence has
so many different
faces and I want to talk in particular
about digital violence women are
harassed threatened and sworn at on
social media every day and that attacks
your intimacy your privacy because we've
all got our uh phones in our hand one in
10 women in the EU has had to deal with
harassment online that is a terribly
High number but it's not shocking is it
I'm one of those women who suffered that
kind of discrimination that kind of
harassment
online if women have a strong view then
they're quickly attacked they're
overwhelmed with
attacks that
includes attacks from the political
right in this house we can't allow women
to be driven out of the public sphere
women shouldn't be afraid for their
safety and their mental and physical
health we need to take online harassment
as seriously as harassment in real life
and we need to clamp down on it with
everything we have in the rule of the
law if we're going to have a lively
democracy then women have to take part
in that political discourse thank you
thank you and now Madame Lang has the
floor president commissioner Yes means
yes no means no we repeat this like a
mantra and we've been doing it for
Generations my mother said something
similar on the streets at the beginning
of the 70s we keep saying it time and
time
again and what is said is that it's not
that the little girls need to be
properly educated it's the little boys
and Justice Minister Bushman you're
blocking of the legislation is
shameful it brings shame on the European
Union what is going on Germany's already
ratified this you've ratified we've
ratified the UN con convention the UN
Istanbul convention and the same applies
to the convention on disabilities many
women who have a disability have also
suffered domestic violence or uh
gender-based violence too and then
Justice Minister Bushman is throwing a
spanner in the wheel saying that there's
no legal basis but that is a
lie Mr
CL thank you Mr chair uh dear
commissioner dear colleagues almost
736 million women over 15 years of age
around the world have experienced a
violence uh from an intimate
partner these are not only the world
bank statistics these are the vote the
voices the faces and the lives of women
that require our urgent action I will
give you an example from Croatia
amendments to the criminal C criminal
proceed procedure code have been
announced uh announcing the the
introduction of um ficd uh as well as
the prolongation of prison sentences for
perpetrators the this is a good step
forward we have to agree on that but we
need to facilitate reporting violence
allowing better access to V women
victims uh of violence to Justice and
provide them more support we need to uh
deal with these structural
inequalities the majority of
perpetrators remain unregistered un
unreported and
uh because of fear of rep of reported
reporting and the pandemic has
exacerbated the problem uh last year
according to the UN data violence
increased uh more uh than in the past 10
years almost 89 thou
89,000 uh women and girls experienced
violence only weak persons use nence
violence in order to feel feel great we
should not shut uh down our windows we
should speak loudly and report violence
in that's that way we will introduce
change into our societies and achieve
equality thank you than L thank you very
much now I'd like to give the floor to
Mr Lopez
agila
gracias thank you president and
commissioner here in the European
Parliament we are discussing the
international for the El elimination of
all violence against women therefore
it's important to underscore that during
this term we have been able to bring
about the ratification by the EU of the
istan Istanbul convention a great step
forward in eliminating violence against
women a
standard common standard in the
EU and there are countries like Spain
which are really spearheading this
effort some are behind but we should
look at the legislative effort that
we're carrying out this directive on the
protection of victims and the directive
on violence against women these should
be completed before the end of our term
and the implementation also of
the uh human
trafficking to assist victims in work
trafficking but also sexual trafficking
and
prostitution that takes place in the
European Union obviously the EU needs to
legisl legislate determinedly against
this now this work shows the fact that
we need to complete the convention on
the human rights to make sure that there
is no discrimination or violence against
women that that would then be considered
a violation of Human Rights fully thank
you B
good morning colleagues the next speaker
is Mr
B thank you Mr vice president vice
president of commission ladies gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen over 50% of the EU
population
225 million people are
women uh in this day and age we when
we've uh adopted the Democrat values we
uphold human rights and they
are at the basis of our society and we
still talk about the violence against
women this is a Scourge a real Scourge
that affects too many women from
physical abuse to economic dependency
from traditions and Customs that still
teach women to be forgiving and places
where women places women are not uh safe
women uh who have to walk alone at night
and all of this needs to be considered
forms of violence against women we can
adopt legislation we can impose
legislation when we're doing that but in
order to do away with violence we need
to change mindset we need to educate our
boys and men and tell them that violence
against women cannot and will not be
tolerated by our societies by every one
of us thank you very
much thank you very much the next speak
is Elizabeth
venberg thank you
president today we're
discussing violence sexual
violence and
violence in
war around Europe where uh women have
been raped
and families have been left without any
hope throughout our our world in periods
of Peace women are subject to violence
and this violence is on the
increase now with regard to the
directive and the legislative proposal
which by the way should include rape
which should be defined this legis
legislative proposal is not going to be
the only way that we're going to be able
to reduce violence we need to adopt a
different tactic we need to cooperate
with civil society
organizations um in order uh to do
something about this situation sexual
violence let's remember is based on a an
erroneous idea with regard to gender
equality and it is our duty to train the
new uh Generations so that young people
learn from a very early age that we are
all human beings regardless of our
gender thank you very much the next
speaker is
Miss there is no
better way to celebrate 20 the 25th of
November would be to adopt the directive
a good directive that would mean that we
would put an end to violence against
women make progress in prevention and
improve the treatment of victims and
their families now the European
Parliament has a clear position having
said that the member states the council
have to include rape as a crime against
women based on the ACT based on consent
Yes means yes
now it is excellent that the insto
convention has been ratified by the EU
and is now uh being
implemented we cannot take any steps
back we cannot accept that the directive
on violence against women would be
defanged because of
the right meaning that thousands of
women continue to be killed for the
simple reason that they are women all
women must be up to this task to protect
women out of respect for women and out
of respect for our fundamental rights
thank
[Applause]
you thank you very much now I'd like to
give the floor to miss
yon thank you president Madame
commissioner rape G mutilation physical
violence
harassment um human trafficking for for
marriages before the age of 18 these are
the things which one woman out of three
can expect during the course of her life
and this really sense shivers down your
spine but these aren't just figures
these are the lives of women of children
of daughters uh we must firmly respond
in Europe a woman should be able to live
a Fearless life she should not be afraid
all the time we reject all forms of
violence be they sexual physical moral
Financial psychological online and
offline so I would call on a joint
action on the implementation of policies
and laws which would be stricter to
protect these attackers to to to protect
the victims from their attackers we need
more than slogans we need something to
be done in reality education is
key girls and boys have to learn all
about consent right from the beginning
this is the way we'll fight against VI
violence and discrimination this is part
of the uh Simon Vale package which we've
set up in the renew group we must ensure
that Zero Tolerance prevails in Europe
and let's act
now thank you very much now I'd like to
give the floor to miss
carvalo
commissioner
colleagues since the beginning of this
year 15 women in my country died at the
hands of their current partner or a
former
partner last year there were 22
femicides these were former or current
relationships and these numbers which
are shocking don't just apply to
Portugal violence against women
continues to be deeply rooted in many
member states we have to act together to
resolve this problem which affects us
all the EU is much more than an economic
block promoting the well-being of EU
citizens is laid down in the treaties as
is the fight against discrimination in
all forms as is the promotion of
equality between men and women
gender-based violence does not belong in
our joint
space anyone who acts violently towards
women is doing something unacceptable
and that applies to what happens within
our borders and outside our borders this
needs to be crystal clear for everyone
in February this year the council
finally approved the ratification of the
Istanbul
convention but it's so Paramount that
all 27 member states now do the same
it's also vital that we adopt a
directive which will criminalize all
forms of violence against women
including rape based on lack of
consent it's not just about values we
have to
uh make those perpetrators responsible
silence in action and in action are
forms of complicity with violence thank
you thank you very much now I'd like to
give the floor to M
olon thank you very much president
commission 20 million victims per year
around the
globe we've given some of the names of
those victims that were killed by their
intimate
partners for
example a
nurse recently
killed a long list of women including
Karine who was killed by her
husband now there were four women that
were recently killed by their Partners
in Sweden
on a daily base uh 50 women die on a day
in Europe for the simple fact that they
are
women now this could also happen no
doubt in front of the children we must
stop this better EU legislation to
eliminate violence against women is
needed thank you now thank you very much
i' like to give the floor to miss
SEO home should be where one feels and
is safe but for many women it is a place
of fear and
insecurity they are afraid for their
lives and the lives of their children
domestic violence is not always visible
and victims are often afraid to speak
out to seek help and Afraid of the
consequences if finally they would
manage to escape on the day for the
elimination of violence against women my
message is clear domestic violence is a
crime and it is a human right to be
protected from it
everywhere and we must move forward with
legislation that's why I call upon the
six EU member states that refused so far
to ratify the Istanbul convention to
protect women
everywhere and to the victims You are
not alone don't feel embarrassed don't
hide speak out I want you safe I want
you
alive thank
you thank you very
much I'd like to give the floor to miss
clut and on this International day uh
when we remember violence against women
and we acknowledge that it does exist we
should think of all those women and
young girls in war tone conflict areas
uh who are victims of unspeakable
torture and violence uh violence against
women in all its forms is a weapon of
war and is being used as we speak today
as as a weapon and here here in Europe
one in three women has experienced phys
physical and or sexual violence me many
of it goes unreported due to issues such
as uh silence stigma and the reluctance
to share because of its reception in our
societies it is crucial that we break
barriers to ensure effective
intervention and the eastanbul
convention was designed to do that it's
with all its requirements would need to
be implemented across the European Union
and all members States need to recognize
that the convention recognizes all forms
of violence psychological stalking
physical sexual including rape and
sexual harassment we need to provide
support for victims of violence and help
them to engage with our legal services
to share their stories and we thank all
those who have come forward who have
been brave they have empowered others
they've Al also shun a light on the
issues surrounding uh violence against
women particularly in the area of rape
and sexual assault so today we think of
all those women who are victims of
violence and assault in our communities
and we call on all member states to
ratify the Istanbul
convention thank you very much now I'd
like to give the floor to Mr
maage thank you Mr President uh
commissioner the International Day for
the elimination of violence against
women is an opportunity to raise
awareness on the dark statistics and
danger that girls and women around the
world are faced with it is estimated
that
736 million women around the world
almost one in three women have
experienced physical or sexual violence
at least once this year's Global
campaign marking the 25th November
invites governments around the world to
present present their actions aimed at
preventing gender-based violence and the
ca campaign slogan is no excuse I would
like to use this opportunity to send the
message to the EU member states
discussing in the council the new EU
directive on combating violence against
women and refusing to classify rape as a
European crime dear colleagues from the
European governments there is no excuse
for that sexual violence is one of the
most prevalent forms of violence and it
is high time we penalized it as such I
welcome the commission's efforts and I
invite the council to make sure that the
EU is free from violence from sexual
assaults and rape uh and to finally send
a clear message that only Yes means yes
thank
you thank you very much I'd like to give
now the floor to miss
pitp every day we hear more about
violence perpetrated against
women uh this is still considered to be
the weaker sex that can be dominated the
figures aren't going down which is why
we need decisive action because
unfortunately any attempts made to
sensitize people to make them more aware
are not any attempt is not
sufficient this is a
very uh Insidious phenomen which can
lead to death we need to ensure that the
appropriate measures are taken so that
stalking is recognized as an offense in
all the member states so that rape is
recognized as a European offense there
shouldn't be any attenuating
circumstances we cannot tolerate the
aggressive attitude of men simply
because of their culture uh let's make
sure that uh we can report women or
women can report men and the violence
perpetrated against them regardless of
their social background let's protect
women with disabilities because the
figures tell us that they're uh
discriminated against two times over
compared to women who don't have
disabilities and let's stop the inhumane
forced sterilization of women who have
uh who suffer from disabilities so women
um are supposed to obey they're not
supposed to annoy uh men uh men say if
you annoy me well I'll kill you this is
something which cannot exist in Europe
or elsewhere in the world for that
matter thank
you thank you the next speaker is
Alexandra
morti in recent days my country has
been completely overwhelmed by the
murder of uh M chitine by her previous
partner what we see is that in every 3
days someone is killed by a partner or
an ex Julia chetin could be our sister
our daughter our friend so laws are not
enough what we need is an education to
put an end to that misogynistic
patriarchy that kills women we have to
start by educating our boys because
feminicide is a problem of men boys not
our girls men that aren't able to accept
this so This should become a mandatory
subject matter of mutual respect uh with
education on affection Love and sexual
education to make sure that the
well-being of women is protected and in
some cases their life now we have to
stand up and speak to make sure that we
we fight all of this that continues to
kill
so young people please stand with your
sisters your mothers and your and all
women because we know that this
continues to kill them thank
you thank you very
much I'd like to give the floor now to
miss maxova
thank you very much chair commissioner
colleagues
today in the 21st century domestic
violence and violence against women is
prevalent and crisis are exacerbating
this further in the European Union every
third woman has been victim every 10th
woman has been victim of sexual violence
and every 20th woman was
raped gender violence found its way onto
the internet every other woman was
exposed to it there
one half of women have been uh victims
of psychological violence in the hands
of their Partners this has major impacts
on the health of the victims and their
families unfortunately we still live in
a world where we cannot feel 100%
safe not only when we are outside after
the dark but even when we're inside at
home because the most common
perpetrators are within our own
households the European Parliament has
taken a very ambitious stance uh in this
directive it is going to be a difficult
fight but I believe that in the end we
will prevail and find a good compromise
that will include a definition of uh
rape and important points for victims
such as the monitoring systems and legal
aid thank
you thank you very much much the next
speaker is Miss
lorti thank you president dear
colleagues just a few days ago we were
talking uh about this Italy has been
really shaken by the um teth woman who
was killed Julia chatin who was killed
by her former fiance um were really sad
um but really very cross there was a in
Padua there was a demonstration
organized at the University where she
was about to uh be uh conferred with her
degree um at the request uh for a moment
of silence um these students decided to
make noise they use their keys and and
their um water bottles um to express
their
uh their annoyance uh at this uh
phenomenon what is the cause of this
it's the um the hierarchy between the
genders which has always been to the
benefit of uh men this despicable uh
phenomenon as it was defined by the
president Mr matella has to be um fought
against by starting uh at school level
we need a proper cultural revolution
which will have to begin with all of us
thank you m
thank you very
much the last speaker is Mr
teres dear colleagues it is odd to hear
leftwing MPS today pretending to care
about violence against women when in
fact they constantly vote to undermining
the identity safety and protection
offered to women by the law there's no
bigger threat or form of violence
against women than to claim or even vote
that there's no difference between men
and women or that any man who pretends
or claim to be a woman should in the
eyes of the law be treated as a Woman
based on this absurd premise male
perverts who pretend to be women are
allowed now in different countries to
serve criminal sentences in female
prisons where some of them physically
and sexually assault women Sportsmen who
failed in their male categories they are
not allow are not allowed to compete in
female sports category where they
obviously win
male pors who pretend to be women can
work fully exposed in women's spas or
even women's restrooms without any
repercussions men and even ugly men
compete now in women's beauty contest
where they absurdly even win the legal
protection that we must offer to women
against any kind of violence must start
from the premise that a woman is
different than a man biology and
genetics are real while gender ideology
and trans activis ISM clearly leads to
violence against women allowing a man
who pretends to be a woman to be seen in
the eyes of the law as woman is exposing
the actual woman to violence
discrimination and abuse in ways never
seen before and is insanity must stop
thank
you thank you very much we come now to
the catdi procedure I've got seven
request quests and if you all stick to
the allocated time I can give the floor
to you all so I will Begin by krina
kinichi thank you president commissioner
not the day for the elimination of
violence against women against
women these are the words that I used
women and girls are subject to all sorts
of violence simply because they're women
now the reality of the figures in the
world and in the European Union is
simply dramatic now Julia
Chin's
um fate and I would like to thank
president metsa for having um mentioned
her in uh the house here she could have
been one of us and the boy who killed
her could have been one of us Sons so
yes we do need the new directive yes we
do need to join the Istanbul convention
but we have to educate we have to
prevent uh and yet this is not
sufficient we need a cultural change a
far-reaching change which involves all
the institutions schools universities
the social media institutions so that we
can do away with this mentality of
control against women thank you
thank you very much next
speaker machas
n ladies and
gentlemen Europe must be on the side of
women and girls Europe must be a safe
space Europe must be a place without
violence abuse and sexual exploit ation
for those reasons we need a harmonized
EU framework that's what we're
negotiating on on the table we have a
directive on gender-based violence and
domestic violence the European
Parliament has been very Progressive in
its stance on that directive which must
of course be in line with the Istanbul
convention and rape of course must be
listed as an offense under that
directive only yes means yes and of
course any sexual relation must be based
upon consent however there are some
member states who do not want the
offense of rape to be subject to
harmonized
definition across the EU we in Slovenia
have a law which means that only Yes
means yes other countries should follow
suit and provide This legal protection
thank you very much that needs to happen
before the end of this parliamentary
term thank you very much next speaker
Barry
Andre uh president uh commissioner and
colleagues the murder of ashleen Murphy
in January 2022 forced a collective
Reckoning with violence against women
that is anything but random over one
year on from ashen's death and ahead of
the International Day for the
elimination of violence against women we
must ask ourselves what has changed for
the women of Ireland according to
women's Aid 24 4 women have died
violently in Ireland since 1996 the
national women's Council recently warned
that violence against women is at
epidemic levels in Ireland Late Night
Safety is a serious issue with fear and
harassment a reality for many women
today serves as a stark reminder of the
need for practical and impactful
initiatives to combat gender-based
violence Vienna for example has been
committed to gender mainstreaming since
2000 high quality public lighting and
improved safety measures and under Grand
car Parks have been implemented as well
as this tougher sentencing needs to be
imposed For Those who commit
gender-based violence judges cannot
impose minimum sentence terms in Ireland
while in the UK they can in fact the
judge presiding over Ashley Murphy's
case lamented that he did not have the
power to do so given that the case was
so far up the scale of gravity thank
you thank you very much next speaker mck
Wallace
thank you very much president violence
against women is
barbaric over 3,000 women have been
violently killed in Gaza in less than 50
days Israel has Unleashed its Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse on the women
of Gaza death famine war and Conquest it
has given them two choices leave Gaza or
die more Palestinian women will be
killed not just with bombs and bullets
but from hunger and EP emics the handful
of Aid trucks into Gaza is a cynic
public relations P humanitarian
corridors paes in the shelling these are
vehicles to facilitate the depopulation
of Gaza just as the two-state solution
has become a fig leaf for inaction for
allowing Israel to continue with its
settler Colonial project where's the
outcry for the women of Gaza where are
our humanitarian intervention is now the
ones who web crocodile tears for women
and human rights in Ukraine Iraq Syria
Libya Afghanistan Yemen just to justify
armed shipments on war to make you
sick thank you very much so uh now the
next speaker is uh Luda
Novak
commissioner if we are to solve the
issue of
violence
well of course uh women are sometimes
physically weaker and that exposes them
to
violence
and so we see that
in society even in Democratic
societies uh violence though
is due to a lack of uh violence is due
to uh a lack of responsibility you know
imagine you have a father who beats his
children that can blight the children
for their whole lives if I look back to
my own
childhood the best memories I have from
my childhood are my parents who had
mutual respect for each other who cared
for each other and that is the very best
thing that children can receive from
their parents and of course uh we need
education too because that can improve
things as well thank
you thank you very much I now give the
floor to miss Le
Mar
the increasing importance of digital
aspects in our life cyber violence has
become a huge problem for women one in
every 10 often young women have been
victim of uh harassment or uh VI digital
assault Revenge porno for example with
images or videos that are explicit are
shared without
consent throughout the EU we must do
more to make sure that our digital space
is a safe space for women and girls
preventing rather than fighting what is
frequently something that cannot be
undone and we have to make sure that
this doesn't happen cyber violence
against women and girls is a
Scourge an IT Scourge that is a threat
to all of us and we should all therefore
fight without ever giving up thank you
very much next speaker clar
Dy thank you president I think it would
be utterly hypocritical of us to Mark
International Day for the elimination of
violence against women without calling
for a ceasefire in Gaza because what
greater violence is there than murder
and in the last 47 days at least
3,800 Palestinian women have been
murdered in Gaza by the apartheid state
of Israel 800,000 of them have been
displaced 50,000 of those are pregnant
against a shattered Health Service
they're undergoing cesarian sections on
Hospital floors without anesthetic
register and recognize the violence of
that now the UN special rapor on
violence against women has said that
since October 7th The Assault on
Palestinian women's rights has reached
new and terrifying Dimensions but this
hasn't only started in October
Palestinian women have endured years of
V ruthless violence under Israeli
occupation ahead tamini was a symbol of
Israeli of Palestinian resistance in
2017 when she was imprisoned at the age
of 16 she's now back in prison again we
have to stand by all women release ahead
tamini
thank you very much now I give the floor
to the very last speaker Fabio
castaldo gra president thank you
president commissioner colleagues now
Julia was supposed to get her degree in
engineering on the 16th of November but
on that day um the that degree uh for
which she fought so hard uh could not be
conferred on her because of Senseless
violence she was just
annihilated her life was taken from her
now according to the UN women data uh
millions of women every year are subject
to physical and sexual violence or both
at least once uh in their lives and this
data should also be
um seen in addition to the lgdp plus uh
data we have the Istanbul convention and
yet Hungary for instance has not yet
joined we are celebrating at this day to
eliminate uh gender diversity but
there's no point in doing this if we're
not United and if we don't work in the
same way there are attempts being made
to dilute this directive at trialog
level and this is simply not acceptable
it is shameful we need to have clear
binding legislation at European and
National level based on prevention on in
education and support for those helping
victims of violence but we have to fight
against this shameful culture of
possession I say this as a man in this
uh hemicycle rest in peace Julia and uh
um apologies for not having done enough
to save you thank you
thank you very much and now to close
this debate I give the floor to the vice
president of the European commission uh
dpra
Chua thank you chair honorable members
we heard many different and shocking
stories this morning but also we heard
figures which makes us even more
alert this International Day is an
important occasion to take stock of what
has has been done and such violence to
to end such violence but more
importantly it gives us the opportunity
to assess what still needs to be done
the immediate and long-term physical
sexual and mental consequences of
violence for women and girls are
devastating and can limit women and
girls active participation in society
from employment to education and
politics president F liion in her State
of the Union uh this September said here
in this
house I know this h house supports our
proposal on combating violence against
women here too I would like that we cast
into law another basic principle no
means no there can be no true equality
without freedom from violence end of
quote just to reply to some uh some uh
statements on Istanbul convention and
this
directive The Proposal aims to acheve
achieve the objectives of the convention
in the area of judical cooperation in
criminal matters it supports the
European Union's accession to the
convention by introducing sectoral
minimum standards while not preventing
member states from maintaining a high
level of protection on one hand the
proposed directive is more limited than
the Istanbul convention because it is
limited to the area of judical
cooperation in criminal matters on the
other hand within its scope it goes
further than Istanbul Convention as it
incorporates uh as binding minimum rules
several of the best practices
highlighted by graio in its
recommendations to State parties and IT
addresses online violence
specifically dear colleagues Dear
honorable members no now more than ever
we need the support of all players to
ensure the quick adoption of this
directive on combating violence against
women and domestic well this adoption
will be an important step towards
ensuring that the people living in our
Union live freely and safely without
fear of violence in a union of equality
let us demonstrate that with our actions
in the months ahead before European
elections thank
you thank you very much
the debate is now
closed the next item on the
agenda is the
following it is the joint debate
concerning judicial
cooperation